welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is yolanta mitts Kuta the Joseph P cause
it's gifts visiting assistant professor
in Baltic Studies at the Macmillan
Center she is an assistant professor of
history at Vytautas Magnus University in
Lithuania and her research examines
political and cultural issues in the
interwar period in Central and Eastern
Europe today we'll talk with professor
Makuta about Zionist women in interwar
Poland
welcome professor Matsuda thank you
thank you for having me here let's start
with an overview of your book project
tell us about it
okay so I'm working on a book manuscript
it's not a book project and it's about
nationalism about modernity and about
Jewish women who are turning nationalist
or Zionist so it's geographically I'm in
interwar Poland that's 19 1918 to 1939
and I'm looking at women who are
modernizing as well as nationalized in a
country that's very monthly ethnic and a
country that has also inherited lots of
imperial legacies from Tsarist Russia
and the Habsburg Empire so these women
are trying to gain political and civil
equality in their communities and their
state the Polish state so I'm looking at
their struggle and their attempts to
gain presence and voice at both communal
and national levels okay and what led
you to study this topic well I'm from
that part of the world so I come from
Lithuania and I'm looking at the great
Jewish Lithuania or lita and you dish
and that's present-day all of
present-day olace away near parts of
Ukraine Poland Belarus and Latvia so I'm
going back to sort of exploring the the
background of my country the
multi-ethnic background on my country
because the president most of the
countries in Eastern Europe are going
sort of setting themselves on a very
National Strength oh no way I'm going
back to the legacy yesterday
multicultural Duggar season okay and
what are some of those multi cultural
legacies what are some of the
ethnicities well we're looking at Jews
or the king at Ukrainians Belarusian
poles and also Tatars and carrots and
also different kinds of religious groups
that's Jews and all believers the entire
was spending in the entire spectrum of
of Christianity and in some countries in
Eastern Europe but I'm focusing on
Lelaina but in some country there are
also Muslim groups okay and how are you
doing the research for the book tell us
about your methodology well it's the
research because I'm focusing on women
and it's a pretty new and underdeveloped
field in Eastern European history and I
mean imagine so it'd be the research
looks a bit like detective work I have
to go into sources into archives and
look for sources in very innovative ways
that's why I ended up using what's
called oral testimonies memoirs
biographies sources that were not
considered for a long time as proper
historical wasn't sources by the
historical profession I've also sort of
trying to tease out women's voices in
different kinds of periodicals or the
press that was left behind because I'm
looking at they went into what period
unfortunately all of that is very
fragmented as we know Eastern Europe
suffered a lot due to the second world
war war so for instance was burned to
the ground
so many of those sources are gone or
very very sort of scanty and fragments
on pc and the piecing a narrative
together about jewish women nationalists
or zionist women in particular in
interwar Poland in that way okay yeah it
must be difficult because I would
imagine women during this time period
and perhaps particularly in that place
wouldn't know necessarily have a voice
that was captured well in any one
particular place very much so very much
so but men were they intellectual and
the cultural event god of many of the
movements in both Western and Eastern
Europe
including Poland but women were always
there that the reason but but we don't
know much about them is that they were
not considered important even though
they're there there were there helping
them and/or they were doing they were
doing lots of interesting stuff but they
weren't know for instance considered
dangerous politically and there's not
much not that much police record on
women for instance communists or women
nationalists but they were there doing
lots of interesting things and that's
why I'm trying sort of to recover put
the women back into the stories that we
have sort of male very male-dominated
stories about into what Poland okay so
how would you characterize politics in
these interwar years I mean how were
some of the ways it shaped Jewish women
during this time well we have intimate
Poland that emerges out of on the ruins
of two major empires Tsarist Russia and
the Habsburgs so it's a very interesting
country that we have all of a sudden and
it has lots of minorities both ethnic
and religious and then it has all these
legacies that are sort of regional I
guess as I call them in my my book
project so all these women depending on
where they come from are very different
and they would provide their own answers
to what their design is dream is all
about
can you give us some examples I mean and
I would imagine all so it depends on how
old you are during this time I mean if
you're an older woman I think your views
are going to be a little bit different
than a younger woman yes a yes women -
women are very much so fractured along
class and gender lines so we have women
for instance if we sort of go and look
at the regional difference is if we look
at Poland sort of eastern Poland what is
called Kressley or eastern borderlands
and we have women who are a bit more
socialist in their beliefs and that's
the Tsarist Russian legacy because it's
an area that was that's close to Soviet
a new Bolshevik Russia and they are poor
and they just sort of dealing with a
different political legacy and different
realities as a result if we look at
women who are living in Krakow or Louvre
at the time and that's the former
Habsburg Empire
they enjoyed a high degree of political
freedom that part of the area and
therefore women are a lot more moderate
in their belief so they're sort of
usually adhering to the
middle-of-the-road kind of Zionism in
their beliefs
now as to differences when it comes to
age yes I've looked at women
autobiographies there is really I found
a treasure trove of sources they were
produced by the Jewish youth in into
Poland or basically all over into
Eastern Europe and it was Jewish women
young women and young men writing and
sending their autobiographies to the
evil Institute in Vilnius Lithuania and
so they are giving me an entire spectrum
of sort of of the least of related to
the class differences the gender
differences I see that the older
generation young woman is a lot more
traditional in their feminist believe
there is still you know looking at
women's roles and responsibilities
through I think a very traditional prism
so they are getting themselves involved
into philanthropic activities which can
be seen as an extension of women's roles
you know as mothers as caretakers as
those who take care of all young people
of elderly of the sick now the younger
women I think are more in design its
movement that I'm looking at and the
Zionist women's organizations that I
sort of explore they are a lot more
individualistic
they also say they're also saying that
we want to be treated as individuals not
just as women they're our role and
function of sort of motherhood of our
childbearing ability so they are a lot
more sort of modern I wouldn't say
wouldn't but more advanced and more sort
of progressive in their views what does
it mean to be a Zionist woman during
this time period well it's a very good
question and it would get very different
depending on who you ask
so as I looked at these very different
kinds of sources someone would say well
let me begin with one major sort of
important fact the belonging to want
movement didn't mean
you were you're going to stay with that
movement for the rest of your life okay
so political allegiances they shifted
even in the course of two decades so
women could you know start as Buddhists
where she was a socialist national
design of organization that wanted to
create Jewish autonomy and in in Poland
what which was were lived and we're not
looking somewhere outside of Poland for
a new Jewish homeland like Zionist did
so some of this woman would switch from
Bund ISM to Zionism and then to
communism times and then go go back to
Zionism so for them they they had their
own reasons for doing that what were the
reasons could you cite any well some of
them would look for new ways to
associate themselves for new kinds of
affiliations because they wanted to
leave the domestic realm especially in
the case of women they didn't want to
stay in what they call the Jewish ghetto
very open in Yiddish or polish and they
were turning turning bilingual and that
sort of another feature or what I call
the younger generation of Zionist some
of them wanted to advance their careers
some of the Zionist organizations had
sports churches and they excelled in
sports for instance so that was one of
the reasons they wanted to join the
Linus man some of the reasons can be
completely trivial
some of them like just to hang out with
boys which was not normal at the time
you had to you know to be with women the
woman leaving at the domestic sphere and
the parents were scared okay so they
said oh my god they are going to this
particular Zionist Organization and
nobody is supervising them at their
dance parties and their lectures voice
and mingling with girls and that sort of
buzz was one of the concerns of of their
mothers and and fathers but of course
there were also very staunch Zionists
coming from families that had a very
long scientist tradition in that one
back all the way to the late 19th
century
so this spectrum you know of of reasons
as to why they joined it was very very
wide okay and how was the how did the
Zionist women women's movement emerge
and did feminism play a role in that
I mean was it you know a way for women
to seek independence and was there a
backlash as a result of that that's a
great question
well the zionist women's involvement in
the movement started early enough
basically with the first scientists
conference there were women
participating and the first is the first
sign is Congress but these were women
who were very ideologically motivated
the I think at larger number women
started joining the Zionist movement I
think with the the Emancipation moment
when women got their right to vote and
be elected and what we saw in 1918 the
Great War was I think that one big
moment in the history of the Zionist
women's movement because women could all
of a sudden participate in elections or
vote in elections and and this period is
very much what with antagonisms and
current sort of ironies I would say
sometimes because for instance and into
more Poland Jewish women could vote and
be elected to municipal positions and
even one of the Zionist women I look at
it was elected to the Polish Parliament
in interwar years but they didn't they
couldn't get into their own Chile's
which were self-governing Jewish
institutions so at the communal level
they could not get any official
representation by women of course they
were unofficially consulted behind the
doors backstage about issues related to
children related to the elderly women's
issues as well but at their own
communities they actually had no women
representatives for us in the Polish
state because of the changes many many
big changes that the Great War and get
women the right to vote so there is a
there's a number of factors that propel
design is women's participation in the
Zionist movement okay are there any
women in particular who stick out that
you've studied yes one of them I already
mentioned the the Parliament member
Meltzer over Oh
Meltzer in Polish she was a very
well-educated woman from what's called
girl issue or that's that's the that's
the part of Poland that once belonged to
the Habsburg Empire so she spoke both
Polish and German was very well educated
had studied in Leipzig Vienna and Berlin
and then she came back and got very much
involved in politics at first of course
and different kinds of social activities
and philanthropic activities in her own
City and then she sort of applied her
expertise in other areas as well as and
then she got elected okay but she was
not reelected for the second term so
they and even even if you know she tried
but she just for many reasons political
and social she couldn't and there is
another very interesting character that
I look at and it's a woman who is
extremely feminist and ahead of the
times and that's Quora Koska and she's
the translator she knows French and but
she is like many other women is a
Yiddish speaker okay and she comes from
what I call the crazy eastern
borderlands that's close to where I come
from Lithuania okay and she is saying
that women and man had to share
household chores okay he cannot just
grant women rights formally you know
politically you can you can give women
rights you know you can say okay we'll
fight for women social equality but she
said let's share this work that women do
at home as well because you know women
can get all these other rights but then
it's it's a double burden they're doing
right they have the job but then develop
a home they have a second job at home
how has she perceived she during that
her time she was considered around a
radical feminist but she also was a
celebrity in Wasel which was the capital
of Poland and still is she I think
didn't care much about public opinion
because she don't was her first husband
and that was that she married through
shitty
arranged marriage because the marriage
was not working at some point she
established her own school for girls and
then she remarried to a guy that was a
lot younger than she was and it seems
that she didn't right so what did she
have a wealthy back
did you know he was not coming from a
wealthy family and that's part of her
I think disliked a woman who were coming
from richer families who resented what
she called salon of bourgeois Zionism
because they were not very well
acquainted with the masses of Jew Jewish
women and there is this strong
I'd say tension that existed between the
Zionist women of different social
backgrounds so the Zionist Vanguard or
the Zionist idea lower usually a woman
who were coming from middle class upper
class families and they were
well-educated in a way they didn't know
how to speak to the masses of Yiddish
speaking Jewish women who were a lot
more socialist and I think a lot more
radical when it came to their rights as
individuals because they were influenced
and it was kind of it
bye-bye socialist ideas interesting how
did the Zionist women interact with
other women of different faiths and was
there a push for feminism overall in
Poland during this time yes Polish women
are going feminists to all all of the
groups all of the groups are going
feminist and of course there's a lot of
pushback there's quite a bit of hysteria
about this new woman the modern woman
and both Polish language and Yiddish
language Jewish and non-jewish Daley's
now women's participation in the public
domain is I think it's controvert
controversial to say the least
many of the men's basically are saying
that women are not ready that they are
not skilled enough to participate in
politics and modern politics but how
will they learn to participate if no one
is letting them in right they're still
saying that today this argument that I
see cropping up and into one years they
are again cropping up and the 21st
century
about that a little bit well we are now
we now have Eastern Europe there has
been independent from the USSR for about
27 years so we are going into this third
decade of independence interwar years
well those were two decades of
Independence
and now we again a kind of recycling
these very same arguments that I look at
in my work like that I know women should
stay at home should be homemakers mostly
and there are certain kinds of course
religious arguments social arguments
political arguments that are employed in
present day in president Eastern Europe
but all of this Hollow has to do with
with the family with the conception of
the family the locust I'd say of power
relations when distribution so we're
going back to interwar debates about
divorce about about contraception about
abortion and all of these debates are
there in interwar years because it's a
very new thing but it's also related to
the emancipation the emancipation ideas
about women so they're also again in
Poland as we know Poland has just
recently elected a very conservative
government that has tried to put a total
ban on abortion a complete ban no matter
what happens to a woman there would be
no abortion period so some of these
debates I can see I can see sort of can
be easily traced back because so what
was going on in interval yes and the
nationalist discourse to write
nationalist discourse because Poland in
interwar years was a multi-ethnic
country but they posited post as that
titular primary identity that everyone
sort of had to aspire to so at some
point many of the of the people were
pushed issues you know what identity
they wanted to belong to even though
many of the people in at the time well
bilingual already or even trilingual in
some places and so ultimately what you
conclude in your book well I think when
I started my research instead of reading
all this sources I was finding was I was
a little bit disappointed would be what
the woman the women's movement achieved
and designed this woman some woman was
achieving at the time but now as I look
back and as I see what's happening these
days I think that we are actually
building on the achievements of this
woman and then we should not build it or
what they achieved at that period
because it was they were coming coming
from a complete
different background and sort of the
historical background as well women
women's presence in the public domain
was so unusual and there's something we
take for granted these days so I think
just I need to take a step back and sort
of try to avoid and what we call
historical hen hindsight as much as
possible because their achievements are
actually quite quite impressive
okay very good it's been wonderful
talking with you today thanks for being
here thank you thank you for having me
here it's been a pleasure for more
information about Professor MIT's Kuta
and her research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
[Music]